quand vous rentrez dans la délinquence
dans dans ce milieu du grand banditisme
vous avez deux chemins qui vous
attendent c'est la mort et la prison
c'est une figure du grand banditisme
français voici l'histoire de Redouan FID
le braqueur de fourgon blindé surnommé
le roi de l'évasion deux fois évadé dans
des conditions qui sont quand même
hollywoodiennes c'était devenu l'ennemi
minéro charismatique séduisant charmeur
ça le résume assez bien ceux qui
connaissent Redwan fa parle d'un homme
intelligent méthodique doué et adorant
qu'on parle de lui les démons ne sont
pas endormis sont complètement morts
ouais cette semaine dans la grande
Histoire j'avais envie de vous parler
d'un personnage qui m'a toujours
intrigué Redwan FID c'est probablement
le braqueur français le plus célèbre
surtout depuis son évasion spectaculaire
en hélicoptère je l'ai découvert comme
beaucoup de gens en 2010 au moment de la
sortie de son livre j'ai atteint plus ou
moins des sommets au niveau de la tque à
armé des fourgons blandés et cetera j'en
retire que de l'échec il faisait la
tournée des plateaux télé pour raconter
son histoire braquage de banque braquage
de fourgon blindé prise d'otage nous on
est là pour faire peur pour diffuser de
la peur pour mettre une pression énorme
sur les convoir de fond pour qu'il soit
conforté dans l'idée que la seule issue
qu'il a c'est de coopérer avec toi de
t'ouvrir parce qu'il n'a pas le choix je
me rappelle je me disais c'est quand
même peu commun qu'un braqueur de ce
calibre se livre autant à visage
découvert peut-être qu'il doit enjoliver
un peu les choses et quand on voit ce
qui s'est passé ensuite le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que je me suis bien
planté comment par cette évasion à
l'explosif un détenu a réussi à s'enfuir
après avoir pris quatre personnes en
otage nous sommes le 13 avril 2013 à la
maison d'arrêt de ceedin près de lîle
aux alentours de 9h du matin Red One F
prend quatre gardiens en otage à l'aide
d'un pistolet caché dans un sac de linge
sale avec des explosifs il fait sauter
les cinq portes blindées qui le séparent
de la sortie il était d'un calme
incroyable qu'est-ce qu'il vous disait
pendant ce momentl d'écouter ce qu'il
disait de que pour un un un salaire de
misère de pas risquer notre vie et de de
suivre toutes ces indications redoan
fayit s'échappe à l'aide d'une première
voiture retrouvé incendié puis d'une
deuxième avec laquelle il s'évapore dans
la nature tout doit être fait pour
mettre la main sur lui et pour qu'il
retourne en prison 6 semaines plus tard
alors que les policiers le pensent à
l'étranger il est identifié sur la
vidéosurveillance d'un hôtel de SC et
mararne grimé d'une fausse barbe et
d'une perruque à 3h du matin redoan FID
est interpellé avec un complice et
plusieurs armes reconduit en prison il
attend son procès dans l'affaire d'un
braquage commis 3 ans plus
tôt moi je l'ai rencontré quand il
sortait de prison il m'avait appelé en
disant voilà est-ce qu'on peut se voir
pour parler j'ai lu vos bouquins enfin
il connaissaiit mon travail et cetera
j'ai pas vu le breaker de cinéma le
sourcil français la gueule de Durre vous
le verriez plutôt je sais pas euh DRH
dans une grosse boîte que braqueur de
fourgon Redouan fayit se lit d'amitié
avec Jérôme Pierra ensemble il publie un
livre le braqueur se présente devant les
médias comme un repenti reconverti en
attaché commercial la vraie réussite de
la réinsertion vous savez c'est c'est
c'est l' envie de réussir légalement mon
plus beau braquage mon plus beau hold up
mais c'est réussir professionnellement
tu vois le 20 mai 2010 un commando
attaque un fourgon blindé à Villiers
surmarne en banlieu parisienne le
braquage tourne mal les malfaiteurs tire
une rafale de kalashnikov sur une
voiture de police la policière Aurélie
foué est tuée elle avait 26
ans les responsables seront
inéluctablement tôt ou tard identifiés
interpellés déférés et sanctionnés et
ils peront pour leurs actes pendant ce
temps-là red continue d'écumer les
plateaux de télévision et c'est une page
qui est définitivement tournée
aujourd'hui ça vous pouvez le jurer vous
ne retomberez jamais ah en tout ce que
je sais c'est que mes démons ne sont pas
endormis mais sont complètement morts
d'accord début 2011 l'thos resserre
autour du commando de Villiers sur Marne
la police soupçonne Redwan fillite d'en
faire
partie quelques semaines plus tard un
fourgon blindé est attaqué à l'explosif
près d'aras dans le Pas de calé butin 2
million d'euros la police soupçonne une
nouvelle fois Redwan FID
du nouveau dans l'enquête sur la mort
d'une policière municipale tué en mai
2010 sur l'autoroute à 4 dans le Val de
Marne la police a interpellé aujourd'hui
à Lille celui qui pourrait être le
cerveau de l'opération considéré comme
l'organisateur du braquage ayant coûté
la vie d'une policière Redouan fayid est
condamné pour association de malfaiteurs
il est Cope de 25 ans de
prison redouad c'est un garçon qui vient
d'une famille assez nombreuse d'origine
algérienne voilà son pas arrivé dans les
années 60 à crille crille c'est des
cités des usines au milieu des champ à
quel âge vous commettez vos premiers
larsin âge de 6 ans le malheur que tu as
c'est que quand tu te fais pas attraper
bah forcément tu vas gravir les échelons
il a suivi ça c'est-à-dire en quand se
parle le petit cambriolage de bar tabac
de trucs comme ça et puis après on va
attaquer sa première petite agence
bancaire et puis ça va monter en gamme
dans le bandi il y a toujours une
hiérarchie le braqueur c'est le haut du
panier et encore plus dans le braquage
tu as une hiérarchie donc il y a le
braquage de commence à disparaître de
supermarché de banque et puis évidemment
le Graal du braqueur c'est le fourgon
blindé la tirlire comme on dit lors de
son premier braquage de fourgon blindé
il porte un masque de hockey un clin
d'œil au film hit de Michael
man Michael man ça a été un petit peu
mon conseil technique un petit peu une
sorte de mentor de prof de fac et il m'a
donné un petit peu le le mode d'emploi
pour braquer un fourgon Blandé il a la
charnière entre deux mondes c'est pas un
K de cité c'est pas type du banditisme à
l'ancienne c'est une espèce de Cré
créature hybride qui s'est nourri des
anciens il est biberonné au film
américains de gangster mais pas que
puisqueau début il regardait des films
de de flic avec Belmondo et vouêtre
commissaire de
police autre titre de l'actualité ce
soir avec cette nouvelle évasion du
braqueur Redwan F le 1er juillet à 11h18
un hélicoptère dépose un commando
lourdement armé dans la cour de la
prison ultra sécurisé de Réo en scè et
Marne à l'aide d'une meleuse électrique
deux hommes découp les portes qui mènent
au parloir où se trouve Redoine FID
moins de 8 minutes après l'atterrissage
l'hélicoptère redécolle sous les
acclamations des
détenus on devine Redoine faillide sur
le siège passager le véhicule aurait
pris la direction de l'autoroute A1
recherché ce soir par tous les services
de police du pays on avait dit c'est
l'nemi pic numéro 1 on l'a chopé on l'
on l'a bouclé le type de fois il s'en va
en faisant çaon je comprends que ça les
énerve une semaine après l'évasion un
chasseur retrouve dans une forêt de
loise un sac contenant des armes et une
meuleuse électrique quelques jours plus
tard redoan F échappe au policier après
avoir été repéré à bord d'un véhicule à
sarcelle des explosifs et des fausses
plaques d'immatriculation sont retrouvé
dans la voiture redan FID a été rattrapé
et arrêté t ce matin il se cachait dans
un immeuble de crille dans
l'Oise
c'est ici au 4e étage dans cette dans
cet appartement que que vous découvrez
en ce moment que redw fade a été
interpellé ce matin je le disais donc
avec l'un de ses frères et deux de ses
neveux plusieurs armes à feu ont
d'ailleurs été saisies par les policiers
et c'est donc dans sa ville natale que
Redouan fayid a été arrêté après 93
jours de
Caval il attend d'être jugé comme un
être humain il a confiance en la justice
il reste digne il il reste debout malgré
le le régime carcéral extrêmement
compliqué c'est le détenu le plus
surveillé d'Europe les gens qu' ont fait
le Bataclan salabdeslam il a des
conditions de détention plus souplle que
redan fade moi je vais le visiter au
parloir je peux vous donner les
conditions dans lesquelles il est voilà
c'est vite blindé il n pas toucher un
être humain depuis des années il vient
de battre le record d'isolement en
France c'était le terroriste Carlos qui
l'avait avant lui dans la salle grand
procès du tribunal de Paris construite
spécialement pour juger les attentats du
13 novembre redoan FID et jugé avec ses
deux frères et trois neveux pour
l'évasion de la prison de Réo il disait
vous me voyez là je suis en forme je
suis élocant je vous parle bien je je
présente bien mais au fond de moi est-ce
que vous savez ce qui se passe au fond
de moi au fond de moi je suis un homme
effondré mais ça je ne le montrerai pas
toute façon il n'attend rien de ce
procès tout ce qu'il attend c'est
d'avoir des conditions de détention un
peu plus normales un peu plus humaines
il a raconté en fait ce qu'il a ressenti
lorsqu'en fait l'hélicoptère a décollé
de de la cour de la prison sreo il dit
j'ai pris le soleil comme un un goût de
liberté une sensation inracontable celle
d'un hucllos qui soudain c'est'est
ouvert au 80 et à ce moment-là très
honnêtement la salle d'assise vraiment
et le public surtout elle est conquise
pour cette évasion Redwan FID est
condamné à 14 ans de prison le braqueur
qui purge déjà plusieurs autres peines
peut prétendre à une libération en 2060
il aura alors 88 ans
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à me dire en commentaire ce que vous
en avez pensé et à me dire aussi ce que
vous aimeriez que je traite dans les
prochains épisodes et si vous voulez
voir d'autres vidéos vous avez le lien
de la playlist dans la description à
très vite pour pour une nouvelle grande
histoire